Alright, so welcome back. This is course update. Point four, I believe. So I think this will be the last course update for now because I do not want to put out all the information that can fuse with all the stuff that's out there. Just want to put out the useful stuff I believe because this update is really, really good.
I think it's one of my best updates so far.
And you will learn a lot of stuff from here.
So in this video,
we will learn about the highs and lows
that are formed inside a fair value gap.
And you can use this technique to find your daily buzz.
And you can also use it as a model, if you like.
So over here, let's assume that there was a fair value gap,
price came into this fair value gap. It created a low and then it pushed back up and it went into
this fair value gap right here. So this high over here. So let's assume there's a
old fair value gap here, right? Browse right into this fair value gap and create it this high over
here inside the fair value gap. Now, let's assume that we are looking at this on
15 minute timeframe. So once price takes out the low that was formed inside this
variable you get we can drop down to one minute timeframe and look for a
market structure shift. Once we get a market structure shift our next target would
be the high that was formed inside the variable you get. So price is mostly doing
this to deliver price of that makes sense. So you get a market
certificate, then you can look to take your entry and you can look to target the
high over here and that could be your lost take profit level. Don't forget about
the fair value gaps in this leg. You can look to take partials but this should
be your draw on liquidity because price what it does it takes out the low
that was found side of the friday gap and goes to the high that was formed inside
the friday gap or it goes to the high that was formed inside the friday gap to
the low that was formed side of friday up just gonna take out the high that it
will take out the low so this is what you can use to find your daily bias
monthly bus weekly bus you can use it as a model itself so you can see we use 15
minutes and one minute combination then you can use the daily and one
hour you can use the four hour and 15 minutes combination and you can use the
weekly and four hour combination and four monthly you can use the one month and
daily timeframe combination sorry for that so yeah that's literally about it
But for this, let me see if I can find some examples.
I mean, I will find I was trying to find examples in this video, so I will just pause
the video and find some examples in hindsight, and then I'll let you know.